hola lo que quiero realizar en este
vídeo es encontrar el área entre la
región en este primer cuadrante que se
encuentra debajo de la gráfica para
cuando es igual a x cuadrada y también
la que se concentra por arriba de la
gráfica de ye igual a raíz de x entonces
estamos hablando de la región que acabo
de sombrear y también veamos que estos
puntos en este caso es para cuando las x
son iguales para cuando x es igual a 1 y
por el caso de acá es para cuando x es
igual a 0 entonces vamos a empezar a
pensar esto una forma de hacerlo es
solamente pensar cuál es el área entre
la función e igual a raíz de x y el eje
de las x entonces se toma el intervalo
de 0 a 1 y vamos a calcular la integral
de 0 a 1 de dicha función raíz de x de x
así que esto nos está denotando dicha
región que tenemos por aquí todos estos
valores de aquí hasta la línea punteada
por acá que estaría dándonos esta región
y luego de esto hay que restar ahora la
región del área que está debajo de la
función llegó a la equis cuadrada pero
hay que observar que también sería en el
intervalo de 0 a 1 lo que estaríamos
restando de dicha función y entonces nos
queda de esta forma ya esto lo podemos
leer como la integral de 0 a 1 de la
raíz de x menos la integral de 0 a 1 de
x cuadrada pero otro camino o forma de
anotar esto sería como la integral de 0
a 1 de la resta de x de la resta de las
funciones porque fue final al final
tienen el mismo límite de integración
entonces es de la raíz de x menos equis
cuadrada y podemos conceptualizar lo que
éstas integran en lo que nos están
diciendo es que son varios rectángulos
que representarían el área dentro de
nuestra región que tenemos por aquí
entonces y entonces las alturas son las
diferencias que va a haber entre las dos
funciones así que en este caso será lo
ancho del rectángulo y la altura de la
diferencia de las dos
así que vamos a tener otro rectángulo
por acá vamos a dibujar un rectángulo
por acá y todos estos con las x de la
misma forma y la altura como la
diferencia de las dos funciones y luego
podemos tomar el límite como tenemos
este super delgado como detalles
intermedios de esto teniendo así cada
vez más y más y más aproximaciones hacia
tener el área así que esta es una forma
de hacerlo conceptualmente o solamente
utilizar las herramientas que ya tenemos
para calcular el área que hay entre la
raíz de x y la función que está por
debajo y así restar las pero bueno ahora
vamos a evaluar y resolver dichas
integrales y entonces tenemos aquí lo
siguiente nosotros sabemos por el
segundo tema fundamental del cálculo que
podemos resolver la la integral de la
raíz de x como x a la un medio se le
suma al exponente entonces nos queda x a
la tres medios sobre tres medios que es
lo mismo que multiplicarla por dos
tercios y todo esto
de 0 a 1 ahora es menos la siguiente
integral que es x al cubo sobre 3 igual
evaluada de 0 a 1 y bien ahora evaluando
la primera expresión de 0 a 1 tenemos
que es dos tercios por x a la tres
medios no entonces evaluando el 1 pues
simplemente nos quedan dos tercios menos
0 simplemente es la primera expresión
ahora le vamos a restar lo de la
siguiente función evaluada de 0 a 1 que
de igual forma si la evaluamos en 1 nos
queda un tercio simplemente y si le
quitamos lo de cero que es lo que voy a
quedar representar pues nos vuelve a
quedar simplemente nuestra función
evaluar en uno que es un tercio y ahora
sí esta es nuestra respuesta dos tercios
menos un tercio que es igual a un tercio
así que esta es el área de aquí donde
cualquier unidad que hayas usado es un
tercio de unidades cuadradas